وهناك اتجاه حقيقي لنشر هذه الفوائد بصوره
عمليه وغير مسبوقه عبر تصنيع هذه الماده
في منتجات يسهل الوصول اليها وتناولها
والاستفاده من خصائصها الفعاله
هي اكبر مشكله كانت بتواجهنا انه نحن
كسودانيين قيمه العربيه سامعين به كان هدف
نحن الاول نوري الناس فائده الصمغ العربي
نوريو العالم كله بيهتم بالصمت الا نحن ما
عارفين قيمته دي كانت القضيه الاساسيه
انها شغالين فيها فنحن خلال الفتره اللي
فاتت
يمكن شهرين شغالين او ايرنس في الحته دي
انه بس هدفنا بس نوري الناس انه يا
اخواننا ده منتج سوداني
تفاحه
هذه الصناعه الفريده تدفع السودانيين
للاعتزاز بانهم وصلوا الى مراحل متقدمه من
تطوير صناعه الصمغ العربي وان كانت ليست
في المستوى المطلوب بعد لكنها كفيله بان
تجعل العالم يتفاعل معها باعجاب شديد على
مستويات متعدده لدرجه استثناء هذه الماده
من قوائم العقوبات الاقتصاديه الدوليه
التي فرضت لعقود على السودان ابان حكم
البشير وكل ذلك التفاعل الايجابي يخرج من
مساحه صغيره من الاراضي التي تقع ضمن شريط
حزام الصمغ العربي داخل السودان الامر
الذي دفع بكثير من السودانيين للتفكير
الجاد في تمويل مشروع قومي يهدف لزياده
نسبه المساحات المنتجه لهذه الماده
الفريده